24時間何も食わなかったら一蘭華枝は
長い食べるなあ
[音楽]
ブーブーて
結果だけ言う等
ゴミクズでした礼を言う訳させてください
あの時ですねなんだが食べれなかったと
いうとも根本的にダイエット期間中だった
んですよ恐れ代役でハマってたからなんか
24時間食べなくてもいけるやっていう
発想であの企画にたどり着いたんですけど
みなさん今回は違います今回私もオーダー
し生活してなくて毎日ムシャムシャ食って
ますお菓子カレーライスラーメン be
the ハンバーガーはっはっは
4キロ太りました体型的にはだ太りすぎな
体型ではないんですけどちょうどいい体重
くらいになってめっちゃ食べるベストの
状態この状態で今から24時間開けますで
20違いがからこの状態の時にラーメン屋
さんの一覧に入ってあことで替え玉何回で
もできるんでまぁはい一蘭の会妻ができる
か操船してみたいと思いますちなみに普通
にじゃないった時僕回玉の限界にです
そんな芸僕が果たして24時間ダンスでし
たらどれぐらい食べれるようになるのか
検証していきたいと思いますもう今日は
アルミ歩い
[音楽]
niすごいでしょ
こんなに行く
みんなで良い部分を大きくしていきたい
から県贈ります車車車車車
また
いっぱい食べたいんだったりしちゃう
パンッ
満腹ぽんぽんっ
どこで覚えたんスかっく何ねー
4階4階です開きます前回の反省は
ダイエット2だったからくれなかったいつ
かなぁ今回は今すごいショックがかかる
状態で以上めっちゃ食ってる中で24時間
お腹透かすと胃袋が大きいままついている
状態になるから絶対くれるんじゃ前よりか
なるほど
今回は本気の木見せます
[音楽]
そのも先の2たルール前に来た同じ
ポルディ
さっき a
お付き合いしている男性がいますどれ
こちら串平
高専にねえねえプロロード増え食べた後に
カレーメシを食べますおいカレーですね
この空軍なんですよね一覧を食べるとき
替え玉しても食べてるもなるなぁ目変わら
ないんですつまりあずに開けるとそこで
終了なんでこういうカレーなどのカレーを
食べるみたいなありに替え玉
なるほどね
[音楽]
持っています
me
[音楽]
もう無理ロマンティックあげるよー
ろまんてぃあたたちった穴に食べてお席
っていること護衛でも羽生さんの鈍く
600ならないと困るって言うそれより
実践成果があるって事言って片山食べて
ほしいつい
影ましたじゃあ
お店んといてほしいど寒さを感じませんで
俺も懸垂がいい間近
2つの声も聞か中で見てあぁなんですけど
ぶっ殺すみますね
目覚めてくれています
pon
俺ござい
タイピンさあダイエットせないそこでこう
いうんですけど今回はくれますよ俺の
セルフやばや
必要はないっ
[音楽]
あっ
そろそろ勝しましょう
[音楽]
ポップっ
b はいもう夜なので寝ます鐘楼前に応答
さあ是正月し水に入れて24時間お腹空か
せると余裕過ぎですよただ最近つに結構来
て建てイベントだか好きそうな教師ている
ので早めに言われますもうこちらおやす
みっ
[音楽]
あずさーいおはようございます
こっそり食べてるとかないですよまあ
字を着てください
wnn ウェイ
汗としても中は
かんじゃないから良い別注はこの後位置に
付いた失礼なのでそれ終わったら
スクール秒かなぁ
米野町の使用しますこれがます
[音楽]
ていますん
tee
meウズ4時間が雲立っているということ
でありがとうございます今日朝起きてから
安達ボディペイントされてひっきりしてた
んですけども結構を泣かせたね終わって
からもうちょっと編集したりして
ディズニー4時間何も食わずごぼう抜き
ましたダンズ犠牲が続けている時に行ける
んですけど結構普段普通に食べている時に
突然パって辞めるときついもうお腹経験は
グッズ崩している感じですん
食いたくてしょうがないと思う手紙仕組み
である
一覧
ちょっとちなみにですけれどゆれくるかや
ば最高記録御10玉無しすごいんだろうね
しゃぶっ枚めくってるところ俺三者委けど
ね言っちゃったねー
一覧最高を記録
今日でまぁステーキにしてが入ってました
ヤーヤベーのにつけた約2袋でさあ
ラーメンを替え玉する彼女と別れ酸っぱい
ですで言うのではば何その彼氏像全学生に
ラーメンを階段をするようなアップた額の
んだところはバカれた方がいいのでしょう
か
ひどいのジャパすぎるいやあんまり製品と
が出てないのでもええ一般男子に平均して
いた椅子
逆にはじめさあ行く時は本ぐらい
ん食べれる
これは
普段からだなぁとか海のいっぱい21たら
すごいように21たらすごいねー
今回しっかり食べている中で24時間抜い
て挑戦するのでわりとフルパフォーマンス
ですはい10万の時のタブ34キロ増え
てるからいいもう
約4
[音楽]
ブーブーおっおおっおーん4つ選んがここ
た客車3杯目んななんてます
やるじゃないですか進めているファそれ
tv が最初に言ってまして11
車通過しすごいな結構食べますねそしてで
他店さん替玉
2つでもうちょっと待っては泣いてるぞ
なんかいっぱいめくりながらスープも全部
載っちゃった夏グルメ皆さんじゅうななつ
じゃないよ
てょ男子れず殺すからツイッターソロスと
思っちゃうけど
うーんとりあえず行ってみましょうか
そう
ん
そこ今週はそこ魂心家そこ違うラメ+が口
が裏目屋さんねっ近くちゃ一覧やな子
持っていた
思います
どれいう
だれ開けてくだへ
俺で俺ってラーメンでいいじゃないですか
だから外へずラーメンですね
西玉も1個たの時ますにあるというかだけ
じゃん
出て
街いけないけど俺は姉味あのませんあのね
マジでおら食うけどまずんくれなかったら
助ける替え玉は酢酸頼みました買った常に
は貯めなきゃいけないんですけど
無理だったら頼んだけっすよ
余計なものは無しで行かせてもらいます
お願いします
走れちゃうん
これで家も続けるの一人は食べちゃう
気づけないよ
ああああああ
おりの方角いるぞ
現像替え玉10杯頼んでしまったので頭
いっぱいは食べなきゃいけなくなりました
ただいま乗るのは絶対いける頑張りますと
いうわけで1杯目が届きましたできます
は大豆を持っている結構多いぞ
持っていた
[音楽]
ああああああ
20はいけるかんことが諦めてて
[音楽]
いっぱい食べました一杯一杯目食べたん
ですけども一杯目がそんなにもの+くれ
ないんですよ以前まんがツールので避けに
腕どんどん頼んでおきたいと思います
才田町ました
一杯目ですし
て行くぜいやあああ多いなぁ生え打の1回
したらしっかり本取りですねばっちり入っ
てますもう
wh
態度がいっぱいに食べてましたまた全然
余裕でだとに思ってよりパレなバイクが
大きいことに気付いた2杯目です
[音楽]
ネギ
ん
ああああああ
[音楽]
スーッと入ってきたなぁ
って言われた寝ござ
ああああああ
あー
落としている
マンドない上部誰も持っているロボッ
待っていっ
[音楽]
ブーバー今ネイチャーちー g 1
マッチョ
チョンチョン
ドゥサーヤベースープがもう
面月からなくなってきましたスープが
ちょっと使ってきてるこれね全部が少なく
なってくると名誉豊富でのに時間がかかり
ますねいただきます
[音楽]
ん
マッハ
全然よよ
goo
ああああああています
6初めてサヨナラちーさん君をコルベ
車シャーシャー yummy yummy
感謝感謝
またいっぱいたべたい菜っぺ号
アロンソれた
いいいいいい
car
ええええええ
par
pou
dou
[音楽]
douは結果は7階ですねもともとあって
詰めるとはっやはり食べることができまし
た
me結構な涼介深い黙って聞いていたんで
結構助けたいと思っていたらけっこう
もともとたべたべもう1回来るなるくらい
の量できてこれね中越えたらすごいです
本当にもう20時間受けてなかったらマジ
で4加工が展開だと思うんだろ
すぅーっと
パティらーめんぬーぼうパクッ
うってちょっと上がってきた感じもあり
ましたけどめっちゃ美味しかったです
よあとです何だけダメ浴びるようにお
かわりできることなかなかないんですが
一番楽しかったです美味しかった
大成者募集中